hi everyone thank you all for coming
here and I'm very happy to be in by data
given this talk and so the topic for me
to talk today is finding relations in
document with everywhere the prognosis
differently where I typically said
yippee but it's okay if you say it's
something else
so this talk about this talk is about
some of things you can do it's
information extraction and how you can
use EAP which is a specific tool that a
novice or tool that we built at machine
Alice to solve information extraction
problems
this is not a tutorial or a very
technical talk I'm just giving a very
brief introduction to information
instructions for those who don't know
what what it's about and I will focus
mostly on what you can do with it where
what are the applications and
specifically what you can do with epi
where does it help what limitations or
important things it has and so this is a
URL for the project you can you can get
it from github so let me talk before
getting deep into the topic a little bit
about me I'm a computer scientist I
consider myself an application developer
more than a data scientist I'm one of
the cofounders of my of machine Alice I
work as a technical leader in projector
machine alice is a company that provides
other companies with development
services for specially for machine
learning related applications and I was
one of the members of the development
teams of EAP I'm not so active in now
other people is moving forward but it's
it's a really interesting project and
it's about information extraction
extraction information extraction
essentially means that you
have some unstructured documents by
unstructured I mean it's not a database
it's not specifically format typically a
natural language so for example you can
have news articles or Wikipedia or
private document base or patents or
whatever you want to analyze that more
or less automatically automatically and
get this structure data specific
information that you can work on with
other data tools later and so what what
we call what we strike is facts that we
put in the database so for example what
you can do with it you can have a
collection of medical paper or research
papers about genomics as Shannon was
saying well ago
and you want to extract information
about what gene is what genes expressed
which proteins or stuff like that just
like having a computer read and
understand in quotes the paper you you
want to make database of relevant people
and their birthday is just by scraping
and parsing Wikipedia you want to know
about business acquisitions and funding
rounds and stuff like that from news
articles you this one is actually an
actual project that someone did and
licensed from social media post about oh
oh I ate at this place and then oh I I
don't feel very well and identify
foodborne illness outbreaks so there
there's really a wide range of
applications and things that you can do
with this but and ok but in general what
you are doing is finding relations when
they say relations I say it partly
pneumatic mathematical sense is just a
set of tools like you think in a
database but it's not just any set of
tuples it's a set of tuples that have
and meaningful significance or
importance and they are mapped to some
real welcome concept that is described
in this in this document those relations
relate entities that can be any kind of
item that is mentioned in your documents
it can be people places amounts of money
organizations genes proteins whatever
and you can do it well all these words
typically from a set of documents and
for this talk when I say documents I'll
be talking about natural language text
documents and other halves with some
metadata like the publication date or
stuff like that
you can also do information extraction
in another media for example identifying
faces in videos or stuff like that I
won't be talking about that that so for
example if you have a small snippet of
text and you are your entities are
software libraries and programming
languages and licenses you can find a
couple of interesting relationships
there like library a is written in
language B or library a is licenses as
license C or things like that so an
information extraction is about
identifying these two entities and it
finds which things are related to which
I gave you a couple of example
applications most of my examples were
based on public data this is really
interesting
also on sorry in public data this is
also interesting in in private databases
and has really interesting applications
we have done some interesting projects
for finance companies that never let us
speak about them so that's a bit sad but
we do the public demo to show a bit of
that more public data which is called
Yabba crunch and the under demo is
available on online it's it also
includes some visualization on on the
data extracted by epi the EAP does not
do this illustration it's just that's
the data processing but this
because this project is working with
TechCrunch which is a online news
magazine about technical companies and
especially as business-related aspects
of them so we extracted data from that
side and made analysis well as the
example I mentioned before about the
acquisitions between companies funding
rounds etc identifying that and we got
the database of those events that we can
visualize and show graphically the
interesting things of this demo for us
is that actually the people of
TechCrunch which is a website and has
natural language articles they also have
something called crunch phase where they
keep a database format of all these
events - so it's serves as a golden
standard to validate that the data we're
striking is actually good real it's not
mapped one to one because a lot of the
events that are recorded in the database
are not news work those for every event
but you can check that the information
that you extracted from articles it's
actually a really vent so we see a PI
you we analyzed a lot of these articles
extracted a lot of a database with
events from this company raised this
this amount of money in this time or
this company acquired this other company
and stuff like that and we generated
some pretty nice raft then don't be mad
at me because this has no y axis is
actually an interactive so you can hover
over the points and see the amounts and
so you we have here a comparison of
something we can between the actual from
countries and what we extracted
the red line is average money in per
[ __ ] according to their database and
the blue one is what we extracted unless
data points our lines is a bit more
noisy and prone to outlier or outlier
points when you have already less data
but but the information is pretty
interesting and one of the interesting
things of these applications is that
when you when you get your database you
can link back those data points back to
the original surface so this for example
a chart of Indians of dollars invested
so you can see Italy's migration in
January of 2013 there was 600 million
dollars of investments but you also can
click and see which were the investments
you below but I'm hovering over one of
those links and this is actually linked
to a news article sorry no worries as I
was saying you you can see for each data
point what are the sources and have the
link to the original articles in the
website where this transaction is
described so you can go from your data
points back to the original sources and
that's that's one of the interesting
points of this so how all this was done
we built this tool called a pipe and or
EAP so it's a Python based tool for
creating information extraction
applications it's
you can use it as a tool you can use it
as a framework it has several defaults
and built-in components that you can use
out of the box and you can customize
them a lot because for several
domain-specific problems you need to to
change things so the thing with
information extraction is that it's
still a hard problem it's one of those
things that humans still do better than
computers still so what we offering EAP
is it's a hybrid approach you can do
manual tagging of documents but then
this manual tagging can feel an
automatic learning system an active
learning system that learns from that
and try to tag additional documents for
you so we build nice web user interface
because many times you want people that
are not data scientist but domain
experts tagging your data so it was
important that it was easy to use but
what you need to do to create an
application is initially get the
documents inside a yep edita base epi
manages an internal document database is
actually some [ __ ] database and well we
don't provide much tools to import a
thing to it because you can get data
from really different range of sources
we don't know but we have a CSV importer
and you can write your own or convert
your data to CSV it's probably the point
where you need to do more work at the
beginning to start using it but once you
get the documents into the database they
start going through a pre-processing
pipeline where a lot of standard natural
language processes are Donnelly Donna
fit
into or in an end of sentences a tag in
each word for its lemma its root word
which is helpful to reduce information
and make the the machine learning
algorithms work better than tagging part
of speech which words are known as check
tips verbs etc which also helps the
classifier and this is one of the shelf
by the stand for NLP toolkit which is
quite good it's a it's a Chaba tool so
it has some complications to the
installation of EAP because you have to
integrate it but it's not that hard and
it's something that also you these steps
are also something that you can change
and switch by your preferred ones or if
you have some some specific way of
tagging or a different language or
something like that you can change these
steps and then one critical part is
entity recognitions because the first
step and information extraction before
identifying relations is identifying
where entities are mentioned in the text
so again there are standard tools for
that the named entity recognition tagger
from Stanford is pretty good for some
specific kinds of entities like names
places dates amounts of money stuff like
that but if you want to look up entities
into a into a Gasset into a list of
names for example looking at for company
you have a list of company names you can
also do cassette resolutions or you can
add custom rules if you're working with
something that has specific form like
chemical compounds or proteins or stuff
like that so a lot of metadata about the
document is stored doing pre-processing
into the database this database the idea
of it is is that you can also update it
online if you have a source of
information that gets new data over time
for example a new source keeps
publishing new articles that you need to
keep reprocessing updated
and and once you have that you can start
doing extraction the most boring way of
doing extraction but it's available it's
a human base form it's essentially you
have a user-friendly interface and
people can click on those places where
the relationships are pressed are
present episodes are by identifying it
already has identified entities so it's
focused you on part of the text where
and it is relevant for your relation are
present for example if you're tagging an
entity which relates organizations and
locations it extracts from your
documents all places where you have
organizations and locations and you can
say oh this is an instance of for
example this organization is located at
this place I only this is an example
this is in DC's decision etc and
something that works also well and it's
it needs less work for need less human
work is doing rule-based extractions
rules are really simple to write and
quite effective in the sense that you
can get pretty accurate results for
example if you're identifying birth
dates and you see a name followed by two
dates in between parentheses it's
probably a birthday and death date and
so by writing a rule we have this metal
language of kind of like regular
expressions but not on individual
characters but in words you say well
subject open parentheses objects -
anything it's probably a true case
that's ruled through at the beginning of
this relationship you can also add rules
for negative for negative examples of of
your relation and yet you're surprised
on tools for testing these these are
debugging this and trying out your rules
and
distant to be quite effective that the
the examples you extract from rules are
typically good the thing is it's not
very robust
if there's a slight change in your input
the rule will will not find it so that's
where you can use it learn approaches
with where you use machine learning
methods they classify risk customizable
we use by default support vector
machines with some predefined features
which are pretty standard in natural
language processing and from what the
human tag and what a staggers tagged so
there's a classifier the built-in
classifier it's also tunable you can
choose to have high precision or high
recoil that means trying to get accurate
results even if you miss some or trying
to have more results even if you have
some false positives so it's interesting
that that you can switch between one
another so let me tell you about real
use case sorry for the short history
lesson here I'm from Argentina we have a
very dark and shameful chapter in our
history were the military took over the
government and started kidnapping and
making disappear political dissenters
and people who are who didn't agree with
the regime and so in this period that
there were a lot of people who were
killed and never seen again with without
trial and without keeping record and
those are called desaparecidos and and
in that era also many times the family
sort of or those people were kidnapped
and the children of those people were
given to in a clandestine adoption
system to friends of
military so today most of this most of
the leaders of the time have been tried
for human rights violations and most of
them convicted but many people today
about nage didn't know about the real
identity they are children of some other
people and there were given an adoption
never told about it so there are
estimated like five hundred people in
this situation only about 120 have been
found so there's a governmental
organization that was set up well
actually many organizations one of them
was called a archivo provincial de
memoria which means Praveen sells
archives for remembrance and this is an
organization that was given clearance to
access classified military files from
from that era a lot of files from that
era were destroyed but they tried to
recover and digitalize documents to
process them and in collaboration with
the natural language processing group at
the University in Court of Argentina
which works very closely with us
actually one of the guys from this group
is also a co-author of EAP work together
on this problem and what they wanted to
do is essentially work on army
ballotines
where you have to identify personal
movements assignments and transfers to
see who work with within which in which
place most of which were clandestine
detention centers and who worked with
non human rights convicted people to
know were these were these children
maybe well they're no longer children's
and so they manually process a lot of
these documents tagged with metadata and
using the AP they made the rule base
reckon the recognizer for entities for a
couple of reasons
stand for an LPS not as good
as for Spanish as it is for English and
also military that means have a series
of conventions that are useful for
example all personally is always
referred in a standard way by e rank
name and registry number and stuff like
that so actually rules work pretty well
to identify 25 building people in there
and they did several passes of
information extraction this is one of
the interesting parts of Yeti you can
mix and match and you can decide at each
step which way of extracting information
is is better at this step so they
started with rule base rule base works
pretty well again in military documents
because they are very strict and formal
in the language so the way of writing
about the personal transfer is very
similar between documents and once I
have that they captured a lot of
examples and they follow a machine
learning based approach to increase the
recall and to detect small variations of
what the rules have already captured
they clean up by humans to to validate
the simple to make sure that what they
were detecting was was right and again
after those humans marked some negative
examples they retrain the classifier and
make make any pass to detect them and
improve the results so this is the kind
of things that you can do switching
between each other and this is an actual
application of yippee so some of the
results are to see what kind of changes
you have when changing from an approach
to another it's like is that you well in
this process they mostly double the
amount of detected entities and
relations when switching to a to a
classifier for this case that the rule
based system worked pretty well for
other cases user Muller and the
classifiers increases your recoil
much more um but well they really take a
lot of information on this document so
hopefully that will be useful for
investigations in the future so let me
summarize a bit about what are the
strong sized or bad sides of this of
these approaches and from our our
experience working in a single domain
improves a lot your success rate in
general in any case of regularity in
documents hubs like I mentioned in in my
previous example but even if the
language is not different a its you have
much more success in for example a
database of medical research papers that
if you go through Wikipedia which is
much wider in the range of topics that
it covers and what we have right now
this is more technical limitation it
works better on binary relations my
examples were runny relations but for
example actually you have some cases
that relations of larger arity are
interesting for example for acquisitions
you want to say a company was acquired
by by this other company by this amount
in this day so you have for a 4-tuple in
your religion and it can be done with
yippee we did it for e epic ranch and
these people did in this case but it's
not the easier workflow we need to
simplify that a bit but for binary
relations it works really well and it's
interesting for what they call minions
isolate datasets it means some of these
steps that you do need to have a lot of
information from your whole documents in
memory especially when training the
classifier we we don't support any
cluster approaches or stuff like that so
you should have a data set that fits in
memory if your data set is too small
it's not worth the effort for
most of these you can do it by hand or
perhaps you can use only the manual part
of it so I call that this most useful on
a medium say that says something that is
too large to do by hand but not as large
as your memory so that's that the sweet
point actually many of the many of the
parts of it a VIP supports on
parallelization you can do the
pre-processing it batches through
documents so you if you have many cores
or even many computers sharing your
document database that works really well
and you can do it but the classification
fire uses the standard classified list
uses scikit-learn
and it tends to use a single current and
load all in memory okay
something else that we found working
with this a couple of problems that
information extraction typically talks
about entities and we are detecting
occurrences of entities and relations
there's a subtle difference the thing is
that some document might speak about
Barack Obama and some other document may
speak about the President of the United
States and those are the same entity at
least today but for yep it's just two
occurrences of a person but you have
some the normalized data there and you
have to consider if that's a problem for
you or you have to to change things
there's also a similar problem about the
temporalities of events especially when
were kit we need a new sources because
you may get reports of past events and
you don't know a Yeti just doesn't
provide a way to dissemble a that and to
know when you have two reports of the
same event or there are two different
reports of different events
that was a problem when doing yep ik
ranch and you have we we needed to tweak
a bit that because we have news about
well as seen as in this acquisition last
year and the acquisition last year was
also reported last year so we need to
separate those events and not not always
you had the day to disambiguate that so
some tricks were needed there and
another different kind of problems that
you get is that you don't get the truth
from from this you get what the document
says which seems really simple thing to
save it but it's relevant because when
you work it it it with a large document
database you will find inconsistencies
reports information about the same event
that it's not that's not same signal
about each other and you will find
errors or false information for whatever
reason there is but it's sir so if
you're using this data for any further
approach any cleaning process or
identification of problems is probably
needed to to avoid getting the problems
that come with inconsistencies so that's
roughly what I had to say today a couple
of examples of uses of epi information
extraction is a really interesting array
you had a really large number of
applications a lot of people are
interested in this so if you want to
talk more about it I'll be around you
can find me by email you can find me
very twitter i'll be around the whole
conference and I'd be more than glad to
talk about this so thank you very much
to hear me